alors que la situation sanitaire
s'améliore en france le temps est venu
pour l'assemblée d'analyser la gestion
gouvernementale de la crise
c'est l'objectif affiché par la mission
d'information parlementaire après
plusieurs semaines de travail
un document a été publié 70 pages qui
reviennent sur plusieurs décisions
prises par le gouvernement actuel mais
aussi sur les politiques publiques
menées ces dernières années le texte
pointe des faiblesses et des failles
notamment concernant la gestion des
masques l'insuffisance des stocks au
niveau national qui était pas compensés
par des stocks locaux suffisants au sein
des établissements de santé affecter
leur situation et leur organisation
pendant une partie la crise dans la
perspective de la sortie de crise
actuelle la reconstitution de stocks
stratégiques de masques de protection et
une réflexion sur la gestion et les
modalités d'organisation logistique de
ses stocks seront incontournables parmi
les autres points relevés dans le texte
on notera par exemple la situation dans
les hôpitaux le rapport avance ainsi que
je cite la mobilisation sans faille des
établissements de santé ne doit pas
faire oublier la situation tendue dans
laquelle il se trouvait avant la crise
sanitaire et qui a nécessité des
personnels soignants des efforts
d'autant plus important dans le reste du
rapport on trouve des remarques sur les
failles dans la culture de prévention
sanitaire en france un manque
d'anticipation encore les limites de
l'union européenne dans sa gestion de la
catastrophe
globalement le rapport de 70 pages ne
nous apprend pas grand chose ils
représentent davantage un recueil
chronologique des événements réunis en
commission certains membres de cette
mission d'information d'ailleurs
regretté une forme de complaisance
ce rapport d'étape il est au fond à
l'image de ce qu'a été le travail
parlementaire et la vie parlementaire
pendant la période du confinement
travaille essentiellement contemplatif
constate mai
sans en être surpris disons qu'elle est
clémente clémente avec avec les
gestionnaires de la crise
le fait de doter les pouvoirs des
commissions enquête a en réalité une
vocation très spécifiques
je le dire parce que j'ai été frustré
pendant la première phase de la mission
d'information de la capacité que nous
allions pouvoir avoir des débats et
interroger interpeller nos mots nos
interlocuteurs cette mission
d'information va désormais se
transformer en commission d' enquête
parlementaire ce qui lui octroie des
pouvoirs étendus
cela permettra notamment d'auditionner
des ministres et autres responsables
politiques
mais la création de cette commission
fait débat d'une part car elle sera
présidée par brigitte bourguignon député
la république en marche mais aussi en
raison du choix du rapporteur eric
ciotti député les républicains des
membres de l'opposition doute donc de
l'efficacité de la démarche certains
estimant qu'il s'agit là d'une alliance
de circonstance permettant à la droite
et à la majorité de ne pas trop
s'exposer
concernant les responsabilités présente
comme antérieur il faut dire qu'il y a
un exemple récent pour justifier ses
doutes en ou 2018 la commission d'
enquête concernant la sphère benalla
avait volé en éclats suite à des
désaccords sur la liste des personnes à
auditionner damien abad vice-président
de la commission d' enquête sur la
gestion du comité 19 affirment que cette
fois les choses se dérouleront à
l'époque il y avait qu un blocage mais
cette fois richard ferrand s'est montré
plutôt ouvert car notre objectif n'est
pas de mettre des têtes au bout des
piques
on veut apporter des réponses pour
éviter une nouvelle crise sanitaire
le ton sera peut-être moins
intransigeant au sénat la chambre haute
du parlement annonce également
l'ouverture d'une commission d'enquêté
pour la faire benalla c'est la seule qui
était allé au bout des auditions